my name is mark Rogers I am a principal
security researcher at trial flag and
I'm a hacker in my spare time I'm Kevin
McAfee I'm the founder and CTO of
lookout and I'm here because we hacked a
Tesla to build safer cars in the future
Elon Musk is a real visionary we wants
to look at his car and see how good was
it really was it a benchmark for the
industry were there any issues and if so
what were there I have hacked a lot of
things I hacked the iPhone I have Google
glass but the Tesla it took a little bit
of time it wasn't a case of us simply
hacking the car we had to attack one
system gather some information use that
to get access to another system gather
some more information and then finally
use that to get more information and we
were able to get full control over the
infotainment side of the car so in the
case of this car that means you can do
everything that the touchscreen you I
can do so you can pop the trunk you can
hook the horn you can flash the
headlights you can unlock and lock the
car you can switch the car off the
biggest takeaway is that cars are
computers your car has more in common
with your laptop than it does the Model
T and with that in mind we have to think
about cyber security issues just as much
as we have to think about safety issues
with car crashes things get hacked all
the time I'm happy that's why I hacked
the Tesla if I'm not having it someone
else is going to be happy and their
hackers out there who'll be doing this
maliciously so vulnerabilities will be
found
what you want is won't be found by the
good guys so this is the software update
but we worked with Tesla to prepare to
fix vulnerabilities that we identified
as part of our research all you have to
do is clicking install now or set it to
install overnight and your car I'll be
back and they
us out really quickly by the time we get
all talk the vast majority of peddlers
will already you say